I never intended to become a political
activist you know as I just said it's
not my natural you know field but here's
what happened I grew up in a time and
place that was about the best
manifestation of the democratic process
thing you could imagine I grew up in San
Francisco in the 60s and 70s and the
Haight Ashbury in particular and apart
from the stereotypes about the Haight
Ashbury one thing that was definitely
happening in San Francisco as I was
growing up is that absolutely ordinary
people were organizing and making
gigantic changes and it was a fantastic
feeling you know there was a proposition
put on the ballot to get gay teachers
out of the school system and I watched
the fear that that put into my own high
school teachers you know and then I saw
the gay and lesbian community but also
just ordinary American citizens parents
and PTAs standing up and saying oh no
you don't you know and they pushed back
and they defeated it and I've watched
that I watched those conversations where
parents were like wait a minute these
are really good teachers you know I
don't want my kid to lose this teacher
because of their private life that's
nobody's business you know I'm not gonna
stand for that the the Chinese community
you know immigrants very many of them
very poor and many of them not long in
this country they didn't have they
weren't the entrenched elite but they
had organized and they had a real voice
in City Hall and it was exciting because
it meant that there were opportunities
you know for immigrants in the city that
really there weren't on the East Coast
when I grew up and went to college there
so I saw how absolutely ordinary people
even poor people could really show
leadership and have a voice and you know
I saw the the gay community organized
and the women's you know women's
liberation the women's movement
organized and you know civil rights
movement that sort of tail end of it and
I just absolutely grew up knowing that
America was this beautiful shining
I swear if something was wrong you can
fix it and you could talk to your
neighbors and you could talk to City
Hall and you could stage a protest and
you could you know that was freedom it
really was and I really saw wow this is
why everyone wants to live here this is
so good
so I guess having been imprinted with
that I became a political activist by
default because when I am to my shock
you know I sort of grew up and came East
and left this little bubble of peace of
justice and I found it so offensive and
upsetting that there are so many
barriers to people being able to do
what's right or have the society that
they want to have and the people in
power control so much in a way that you
know isn't intended to be the case in
America in terms of our voice and our
access to the democratic process that I
guess just as a function my discomfort
with that I you know I feel committed to
addressing it and changing it all so now
that I'm a mom it really you know lights
a fire because it's bad for kids in a in
a closed society it's bad for women and
it's bad for children I don't even want
to tell you what happens to women and
children in a closed society but as a
feminist you know there is no better
place to grow up than a strong
constitutional republic and there is no
better place to be a woman than in a
strong constitutional republic so we
can't afford to lose those rights
Vernon's